let's bring in a very important man
yahoo sports national college columnist
Pat 40 fearless predictions the 40-yard
dash as we get ready for the college
football season how are you this morning
Pat happy football week to you are you
ready I'm ready because you know what
August has been terrible in college
football let's actually play some games
all right the most important game this
weekend is Michigan Notre Dame okay you
know but Michigan huge credibility
season I think for Harbaugh plugging in
a transfer quarterback who was they had
to jump through a lot of Hoops to get
him eligible I think Brian Kelly's
always one game away from the hot seat
they lose to top 10 picks from the left
side of the offensive line how does
their quarterback do without that so
winter comes out feeling pretty good
loser comes out feeling terrible as far
as the stability for horrible and you
know so if I look at Notre Dame I look
at Michigan the coaching situations
there how dependent are they on success
this year to keep their jobs yeah I mean
I I think Harbaugh is gonna keep his job
unless the bottom falls out but I think
he would remove any cushion he really
has any cachet that you know that he had
built up rather quickly there would be
gone if they don't have a very good
season this year because they really
should I mean I've got a great defense
they bring back their leading rusher
they've got receivers they've got and
now they've got the quarterback so one
thing they lack so it's it's an
important here I don't think it's a win
or get fired year but it sets the stage
for that and then for Brian Kelly you
know I'm again it's it's week to week
it's year to year I Jack Swarbrick wants
him to be the coach for like 20 years
there and last year the start they got
off to I thought you know that kind of
solidified in his mind yeah he's the guy
and we want him to be the guy but then
they don't finish well and they lose
Mike elko who was a rising star
defensive coordinator to Texas A&M
and you're right back in kind of rebuild
transition mode so you know and there's
always a question of how happy is brian
kelly they're not not to mention how
happy is notre dame with brian kelly and
i go back to what i was told this is
probably two maybe three years ago maybe
two years ago that that that this person
wouldn't be surprised if john harbaugh
took over at Notre Dame that you know he
if it he decided he didn't want stay at
the Ravens or the Ravens didn't want him
and it didn't work out with Brian Kelly
like that would be this scenario where
you could see John Harbaugh taken over
for Brian Kelly what do you think of
that well that would certainly be
interesting you know I mean John
Harbaugh is set along and if Ron apiece
ready to try something new
he would be an incredibly attractive
name I think he's won Super Bowls he's
you know have various been very
successful coach the other name
obviously they'll be out there is the
guy who's living in Chicago now who was
the coach at Oklahoma named Bob Stoops
III think he's pretty happy in
retirement but his name would come up
immediately if there were an opening at
Notre Dame Urban Meyer's survived
because why his record is 73 and eight
that's I think the starting point
there's more to it than that but when
went through that's successful people
are going to find ways to to make it to
make the situation look like you're
capable
I think obviously if if there had been
charges against Zack Smith I think that
there would have been no wiggle room
whatsoever but there weren't I still go
back to the fact that Urban Meyer knew
absolutely knew that he had a disaster
of an employee on his hands kept him
enabled him who didn't disclose to his
superiors about exactly how bad this guy
was lied to the public about it did
everything possible to enable Zack Smith
and I don't really understand why and
then I think Urban's reaction publicly
to this whole thing has just been a
disgrace and abomination really every
time he's had a chance to say something
publicly he said the wrong
thing and then tried to come back and
correct it later I'm not sure that's a
fireable offense but it's a very very
bad look Nick Saban has not decided on
his quarterbacking situation and this is
what the Alabama coach had to say
they both had done a good job in fall
camp we're excited about the progress
that both guys have made and what
they're capable doing if I'm ready to
tell you I'll tell you if I'm not I
won't none of that's been decided yet so
I wish we could talk about something
else because I don't really have
anything else to say about it why is he
so testy about this I and I applaud the
local media for continuing to ask this
question because yeah kind of seems like
it's important yeah just a little bit
the starting quarterback for the
defending national champion yes it's
it's fairly important and he's just
about it because he doesn't like being
questioned all the things like this but
do you think oh noes Pat do you think he
knows no of course he knows tonight you
know I think he's trying to keep the guy
who isn't the starter from transferring
you you saw at Nebraska yesterday they
named the starter the other guy with
Drew yeah and he's gonna look for a
place probably to get into right away
and obviously you want two quarterbacks
more than you want one so I think that's
what's involved there that and trying
not to make this into more of a media
hoopla than it is but you know hilarious
when Saban said at SEC Media Days I was
there said you know this quarterback
controversy you guys created wait a
minute you're the one that pulled your
starter at halftime of the championship
game dude yeah sort of and and the fact
that you haven't named his starters so
it does continue to be a controversy so
sure it certainly added to this we're
talking to Pat 40 Yahoo Sports National
College columnist clay Helton USC head
coach will join us on the program
tomorrow
true freshman starting for him what's
the prognosis for the Trojans not just a
true freshman but in reality he could
have been a true senior in high school
this year he moved up his graduation
when Sam Donald went throw and there was
an opening
JT Davis moved up his graduation and
enrolled and has done great I mean he's
been lights out now
question is you know how many lumps are
you going to take with a guy who's 17
years old is your starting quarterback
and especially when the early schedule
includes at Stanford at Texas I think
that there's that's that's a really
steep learning curve you're asking for
their they've got they've got good
players they've got some holes and I
think you start with quarterback there
so I think USC if he comes through it's
one of the better stories in the country
if he doesn't I think the the pac-12
South is wide open and about three or
four teams could win it
what about Chip Kelly you UCLA yeah
gonna take some lumps this year gonna be
a transition year they just suspended
six guys which I think underscores that
he's not really looking at this as win
now you lose Josh Rosen you lose an
offensive tackle who is a top 15 pick
they weren't that good to begin with so
I I think he will get it done they're
gonna be better coached no matter what
this year I just don't think they're
gonna be overly successful right away
now you're fearless predictions you
ready yeah I'm ready
Nightfire way okay I have West Virginia
being basically the talk of the country
going into November they're gonna be
seven and one or eight no and then
that's it they're gonna hit a wall and
they're gonna be done we're gonna
everybody's gonna be talking about will
career for the Heisman it's not going to
happen
Arizona is gonna win the pac-12 South
wait wait are you on my khalil tape
bandwagon yeah I could have used you
last year okay all of a sudden I'm
saying I I think this guy's the best guy
I've seen in college football they're
like who because nobody's watching
Arizona football right because their
games finish it to a every time he's
Lamar Jackson with perhaps better
passing we'll see well I think Miami's
overrated think they're gonna drop out
of the the top ten the turnover chain
was nice it was fun but that team was
kind of over achieved last year I my
playoff predictions are not overly
fearless
because they think the same cast of
characters are there I think it's going
to be Alabama Clemson I'm throwing
Wisconsin in there I'm a believer in the
Badgers this year after being a
non-believer last year and I'll take
Washington I think Georgia could be in
there but I think two years in a row of
two SEC teams will just like explode the
head of three-fourths of the nation and
there's gonna be a lot of backlash to
that so I think they'll find a way to
keep the SEC runner up out of the mix
wait well who cares if there's a
backlash of Georgia's worthy of being in
there oh people will care I know I want
the four best teams yeah you know but I
think there's gonna be it's gonna be a
lot of backlash and a lot of committee
discussion of whether this is a true
national tournament if we're going to
know what Georgia and Alabama again you
know but I think George is gonna be very
good will a quarterback or a running
back win the Heisman who I I would say
right now running back I would say Bryce
loved Jonathan Taylor might be your your
top two candidates and the road of the
quarterback situation not as much not as
many guys that are real brand names at
this point going into the year where is
gonna be the surprise team either
they're gonna be you mentioned Miami's
not gonna be as good as people think
is there a team that people don't think
is gonna be as good who's gonna maybe
contend or at least be in that top seven
top five yeah I mean I like Arizona
maybe not to be quite that good but like
I said to play for the pac-12
championship
I think Boise State's back to being that
kind of line in the ointment program
yeah I just I'm not sure they have the
schedule to support it they're kind of
in that UCF situation but they're this
could be their best defense in a long
time they got the quarterback coming
back a thousand yard rusher in they're
receiving situations iffy but they
they're tough to recruit their receivers
but I could see them running the table
being 13 - no they've got to win at
Oklahoma State for that to happen but if
they do that then then people are gonna
be there's gonna be a big discussion
about boys in what where they should
rank if you couldn't
Notre Dame Michigan this weekend what
would be the second choice probably
Washington Auburn in Atlanta just as a
huge game for the pac-12
in general and Washington in specific
they can't afford a loss there because
there's not enough chances to pick up
quality wins
Auburn can afford a loss and still be in
the mix pac-12 after last year's debacle
needs to get off to a good start just
Scott frost have any more eligibility
because they may need him as a backup
quarterback at Nebraska yeah right after
their starting a true freshman and the
other guy just left you know hey there's
video out there of him running the
option pretty well when he was at
Central Florida and practice so they
made they may well need him they'll be
better this year but probably not real
good but I was huge for Nebraska to get
him when he was wanted by some big-time
programs including Florida Pat have fun
this weekend
always great to talk to you alright
that's pat forty the 40-yard dash Yahoo
Sports for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]